freunde der sonne eis selbst zu machen
ist gar nicht so schwer ich habe heute
hier ein schoko eis mit gerösteten
haselnüssen und kirchen wie auch ein
buttermilch orange eis mit minze das
habe ich gestern gemacht ohne
eismaschine aber mit chemie und wie ihr
das zu hause auch machen könnt das
erfahrt ihr jetzt
[Musik]
die hab ich gerade etwas nie gesagt ja
das hab ich gesagt und wenn dafür keine
chemie ist dann weiß ich auch nicht fest
gehen raus an den iceman of time dass
ihre dein vorschlag also vielen dank für
dieses wunderbare thema eiscreme hat
folgende bestandteile erstens wasser das
wasser kommt aus der milch
beziehungsweise aus der sahne milch und
sahne sind in der regel die basis
bestandteile von eiscreme 21 fed
das feld kommt ebenfalls aus der saane
beziehungsweise aus anderen
wunderschönen fed quellen wie zum
beispiel butter oder schock drittens
zucker als sollte natürlich süß
schmecken und der süße bei kalten
temperaturen nicht so stark zum
vorschein kommt wie bei wärmeren
temperaturen brauchen wir hier nicht so
wenig außerdem eher niedrig zucker den
gefrierpunkt von wasser dieses phänomen
habe ich euch erklärt in unserem letzten
video wo es um getränke kühlen geht es
heißt da könnt ihr euch das noch mal
anschauen jedenfalls wenn man zu wenig
zucker nimmt dann wird das eis zu hart
wenn man zu viel zucker nimmt dann wird
es eventuell zu matschig oder flüssig
ihr ins emulgatoren denn wir haben sie
ihr bei mais mit einer emulsion zu tun
zum beispiel wasser und fett ein
bisschen sich nicht so gut dann setzten
sich die emulgatoren an die grenzfläche
zwischen wasser und fett und
stabilisieren dies grenzfläche bzw
dasselbe passiert auch an der
grenzfläche zwischen flüssigkeit und
luft fünftens kannte sie ob ihr schoko
milch oder vanille oder erdbeer was auch
immer ihr rein tun möchte da hilft
einfach nur ausprobieren bzw
experimentieren hier in meinem fall ist
das hier habe ich einfach so bisschen
zartbitterschokolade mit butter und
milch angeschmolzen hier habe ich noch
mal schokolade ein paar sauerkirschen
hier habe ich
haselnüsse mit bisschen butter und honig
karamellisiert das ist als nummer eins
als normal 2 habe ich im buch ich habe
ich hier orangen frisch gepresst oder
schade frisch kobelt ein bisschen minze
und ein bisschen screen
das problem war einfach mal zwei ist
dadurch dass ich jetzt hier buttermilch
und orangensaft habe habe ich jetzt hier
deutlich mehr wasser im rezept deswegen
habe ich beschlossen einfach noch so ein
bisschen gebräunte butter hinzu zu
bringen um den fettgehalt wieder bis ihr
zu erhöhen gebrachte mutter ist einfach
wenn man butter in der pfanne so ein
bisschen war bis sie gerade brown wird
das hatte ein ganz tolles aroma
normalerweise bräuchte man eine
eismaschine das prinzip eine eismaschine
ist simpel sie kühlt und sie rührt
gleichzeitig das rühren ist deshalb so
wichtig damit sich keine größeren
eiskristalle bilden bzw
größere eiskristalle wären durchführen
sehr schlimme oder zerstört und endlich
gibt es zwei sachen die eiscreme schön
cremig machen dass erst ist möglichst
kleine feine eiskristalle und das zweite
ist möglichst viele kleine feine duft
wird den so häufig übersät aber genauso
wie beim backen spielt luft auch hier
bei mais eine essentielle rolle für die
konsistenz also ich habe keine
eismaschine was ich machen könnte ist
meine eis mischung machen die ins
gefrierfach stellen und über einen
zeitraum von stunden immer wieder mal
umrühren aber darauf habe ich keine lust
stattdessen versuche ich etwas mit den
zutaten zu tricksen und zwar erst das
benutze ich keine milch sondern gesüßte
kondensmilch der vorteil
dies fiel dickflüssig
hier ist viel mehr fett und viel weniger
waffen weniger wasser heißt es können
auch weniger eishalle gebildet werden je
mehr fett in einem extrem ist so
cremiger ist es das liegt aber auch
daran dass das fed die kristallisation
des wassers stört bei vettel was
sicherlich nicht lösen zweitens ich
schlage diese antwort wie gesagt
luftbläschen sind ein essentieller
bestandteil von eis deswegen bringe ich
hier vorab schon mal ganz viel luft lich
sind rein damit ich nachher wenn es erst
in einem gefrierfach lässt nicht mehr
ständig rühren muss als emulgator nimmt
man normalerweise das mache ich heute
nicht sonst müsste man das ganze erstmal
erhitzen wegen salmonellen das bin ich
jetzt zu faul
stattdessen kann man polysacchariden
nehmen die das ganze etwas finden das
wäre zum beispiel stärke letztendlich
auch mehl oder alginat gelatine und was
mir empfohlen wurde war so heiß brot
kern mail doch gestern im supermarkt gab
es kein johannes roth kehren wir westen
stand der boa kern mail was ebenfalls
ein polysaccharid ist und ebenfalls
bindende eigenschaften haben soll das
heißt verdicken gegen wir den kern mail
doch eine chance aber ich denke ich
spielen sollte eigentlich auch stärke
funktionieren
[Musik]
freunde der sonne
einen tag später habe ich als ich habe
es über nacht frieren lassen dann kann
es sicherlich auch am selben tag machen
wenn man die schätze mal so vier stunden
zeit hat ist auf jeden fall sehr grimmig
vor allem bei diesem wetter hier weiß
ich will mich ja nicht selbst suchen was
ziemlich lecker ich kann nur sagen
freunde der sonne probiert es zu hause
aus und wenn er es tut der schicke
bilder über facebook und instagram würde
mich sehr freuen
vielen dank auf jeden fall noch mal an